all right big move for you this year
yeah about a new house yeah Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star Kyle
Richards is trading in her 902 anno
adjacent to zip code and headed it to
the valley what inspired the move you
know I was renovating my house because I
couldn't find a house that I fell in
love with and I saw this house it was
actually one of my husband's and
listings and I said to him I want to go
look at this house and look at their
floors because I was redoing my floors
at the time and he said I'll go with you
and we went into this house and I just
went oh my gosh
and I was completely blown away because
it's not like anything you would see in
Los Angeles normally and I just fell in
love that my husband did too I remember
we called our friend and our designer
Faye Resnick because we've just given
her a check for like the floors marble
all this and I was like what are we
gonna do and so I said you have to come
and help us make this decision and she
walked in and she said I have goosebumps
everywhere you need this home we were
like I guess we're moving done deal
done deal I always laugh with you know
our producers and our DP and I'm like
just I feel like I bought this house
because of you because they're always
trying to look for new interview looks
and backgrounds and I'm like he's like
we've already done that we've already
done that you've been you're selling on
my fine I'll go look I got a bunch of
new rooms for you to pick yeah like here
are you happy now I bought a new house
all for you
you